They're Earth's Mightiest Heroes.
But how much do you really know about the
Avengers?
Here are 10 Avengers facts you may not know.
What's in a name?
When you think of the Avengers, you probably
think of heroes like Iron Man, Thor, Black
Widow, and Captain America.
But it was another superhero who actually
gave the team its name—a character that
still hasn't even appeared in the movies except
in one little flashback:
That's right Janet van Dyne, the Wasp, was
a founding member of the Avengers in the comics,
and even came up with the name, too.
That Nick Fury's always trying to take credit
for everything:
"I'm here to talk to you about the Avenger
Initiative."
Wasps for Widows
While she may be missing from the team she
named, there was a point in time where the
Wasp would've made her cinematic debut in
the original Avengers movie.
Writer/director Joss Whedon explained in a
Q&A session after a screening of the movie
that he'd written the Wasp into the early
drafts of the screenplay:
"There was a little bit of time where we thought
we might not actually get Scarlett [Johansson]
There was a very Waspy draft that I wrote.
But it was way too Waspy.
I was like, ‘She’s adorable!
I’m just going to watch her!'”
Eventually Johansson did sign up, bringing
the Black Widow back to the screen...and the
Wasp got squashed.
Good, I hate wasps...
Hulk smash...membership card
In the movies, the Hulk is one of the most
high-profile members of the team.
However, he was only an Avenger for a single
issue in the comics: they formed in the last
panel of Avengers #1, and by the end of the
second issue, he'd already quit in a rage.
What a baby.
A few issues later, a recently unfrozen Captain
America replaced the Hulk, and the rest is
superhero history.
Kang, outfoxed
As the second movie in the franchise shows,
Ultron is one of the most important Avengers
villains.
But another nemesis stands out as their all-time
biggest threat: Kang the Conqueror, a time-traveling
warlord who has menaced the team since 1964.
So why hasn't he appeared in an MCU film yet?
Because even though he made his debut as an
Avengers bad guy, he's also closely associated
with the Fantastic Four.
And according to Guardians of the Galaxy's
director James Gunn, Marvel included the film
rights to Kang as part of their Fantastic
Four contract with 20th Century Fox.
As a result, Kang is probably off the MCU
table for good.
Avengers disassembled
One of the most infamous moments in Avengers
history took place in issue #16, in which
the entire original team quit, only to be
replaced by reformed supervillains.
Why such a drastic roster change?
Well, because Iron Man, Thor, Giant-Man and
the Wasp were starring in their own solo comics,
and Marvel Mastermind Stan Lee was getting
confused about the continuity.
"Did it work?"
Rather than spend time figuring out each month
when each adventure happened in relation to
the others, he decided to just feature different
characters who weren't appearing in other
comics.
Avengers: Age of Makino
If you've ever looked at Ultron and thought
he was pretty well-suited to be an evil robot,
you can thank a comic book called Captain
Video — specifically issue number 3 from
1951.
According to an interview with Ultron's co-creator
Roy Thomas, artist John Buscema was partially
inspired by the villain, Makino's, creepy
design.
Just take a look at that perma-smile on his
face...
Visions of other worlds
Speaking of writer Roy Thomas, he'd asked
Stan Lee if he could add a new member to the
Avengers in 1968.
He reportedly wanted to resurrect the long-forgotten
Golden Age superhero character who first appeared
in Marvel Comics #13 back in 1940: an alien
known as the Vision, an alien cop from a smoke
dimension who comes to Earth to battle mystical
crime.
But Stan Lee had other plans, asking that
the new addition be a robot of some kind.
So Thomas and Buscema simply took the name
and design for Vision and used it to make
a new, robotic version.
And this one could even cry.
Comic book casting
Follow along with this one, if you can.
"Hold on to your butts."
In the comics, Nick Fury was originally a
white World War II vet who eventually became
an Agent of SHIELD.
When Marvel updated the character in the early
2000s for their “Ultimate” universe, artist
Bryan Hitch decided to use Samuel L. Jackson
as the model for the new version of Nick Fury.
So when Marvel Studios produced the first
Iron Man movie back in 2008, and the post-credits
scene called for a cameo from Fury, there
was only one man for the job...Samuel L. Jackson:
"Who the hell are you?"
"Nick Fury, Director of SHIELD."
Once the movies became a hit, Marvel decided
to make the comic book Nick Fury in the main
Marvel Universe match the films.
To explain the change, the original Fury got
a previously unknown African-American son,
appropriately named Nick Fury, Jr., who took
over running SHIELD for dear old dad.
These days, Nick Senior is out of the picture...because
he's been chained to the moon.
"How's that workin' out for ya?"
Rogue was an Avengers villain
Back in 1981's Avengers Annual #10, the heroes
faced off against the Brotherhood of Evil
Mutants, which boasted a new member: a superpower-stealing
villain named Rogue.
Two years later, she switched sides and joined
the X-Men.
Since then, she's become one of the most famous
members of the mutant superteam...though,
that's partially because of her southern,
uh, "charm."
"You're as fast as a swamp bug on a hot skillet."
Joss Whedon, superhero scribe
On the subject of Marvelous mutants, Avengers
writer/director Joss Whedon actually had the
opportunity to take a crack at the mutants'
first big-screen adventure.
He told the A.V.
Club that he'd been invited to punch up the
script for the first X-Men movie.
So what happened?
Whedon explained:
"[...] not only did they throw out my script
and never tell me about it; they actually
invited me to the read-through, having thrown
out my entire draft without telling me."
Apparently, however, one line he wrote did
make it into the final film:
"Hey, hey...it's me."
"Prove it."
"You're a dick."
Meanwhile, a few years later, Warner Brothers
invited Whedon to write and direct a Wonder
Woman feature film...but the project was scrapped
in 2007.
Incredibly, Whedon's Avengers movie in 2012
earned over $1.5 billion and made the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the envy of Hollywood.
For Avengers fans, there's only one thing
to say to 20th Century Fox and Warner Bros.
for their mistakes:
"Good move."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Avengers fact surprised you the most.